hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to zombie night terror the
game where you are in charge of the
zombies and you get to determine the
deadly deeds that they execute on your
behalf or at least that's what I'm
assuming about the game judged by what I
saw there yes contaminate three humans
to kill 14 so I don't know how to play
this game but I saw the preview for and
looked super cool like ridiculously cool
right up my alley and it had this really
cool styling to it
and I love the name but I didn't want
all bunched a beauty let me know if you
snap it up addition to me mate or not
big enough energy magic pony pay no
panic
Bonilla Matthew even when you can summon
if in ocean water but I believe you stop
it off oh oh I don't think you should do
that
man these pixelated girls like to jump
around and shake their boobs that's all
I know about this game thus far okay Oh
what did I do that oh oh you oh you
surround him oh Jesus
oh good golly oh I played a game like
this but this is so much better
oh man that guy should have run holy
[ __ ] that was awesome Oh what was the
game called it was a game like this can
I see you in there I see you trying to
hide you've been you're in escape Bay
well the answer is yes you absolutely
can but I oh why you do lady you seem a
lot less panic than you should be oh
hello friends where did you come from
alrighty then I don't know if I did my
job
Jesus is it a fountain of blood let me
try that again because I want to get the
overkill I'm pretty sure I know how I
just got to get the guys on the
outskirts so grab this huh blowing
blowing huh boy because I think that guy
in the center already has it he's
already going to be infected huh maybe
oh maybe don't run that with no you
stupid zombie [ __ ] can I scroll oh I
can wait no idea I'll bash down that
door I'll break it open oh that's so
cool oh oh you're dead okay well that
sucks for you oh geez oh god I had no
idea
Oh oh my apparently they're too stupid
to get through doors but maybe I'll be
able to upgrade them and be able to beat
that oh I love this already I really
love this already Jesus that fountain of
blood I did marginally better but I'm
assuming I'm gonna need some upgrades to
be able to get through everything damn
that's a big up TV film elope with Rose
what's it doing here you turn it on
Benigno pay Oh what do I do with that oh
hi hello we are coming to you live from
downtown this lady reporter has an
amazing voice we're coming to you live
from downtown where it's believed the
contamination started kicking baby's
considered to be healthy well that's
convenient for me cuz that vindicates me
of what I was doing
oh jeez okay then locals at the scene
believe the bizarre changes in populace
are from a defective batch of home
cooked drugs our investigation is
ongoing stay with us
April Fox znt news all righty then
well that doesn't sound good oh oh geez
oh God hey come on man don't be like
that
you need to relax oh [ __ ] now why I feel
so ragged have I been munching on
Tainted Romero
uh yeah lady uh lady I'm sorry lady I
feel bad now oh geez oh goodness
gracious
well my job is done question mark
I can't scroll to the oh yes I can I can
give them instructions this is so cool
I'm sorry I'm freaking out I just love
this a lot break down that frickin door
hell yeah
you may not gonna instructed them to get
the guy in the in the dumpster
ah I could've done that would have been
great spread the junkie plague by
killing 22 humans kill every human
without losing any zombies I don't know
if I'm gonna be able to do that okay so
we got guys coming in the front so bad
oh [ __ ]
so that guy can take care of my zombies
oh jeez but there's more over there oh
hell yeah okay
hang on I'm gonna restart this let me
stress reboot so I need to get that guy
on my side before he can feed up any
zombies
oh you don't feel so good oh jeez he
feels really bad right so you in the
supply closet you and you oh this is oh
this is the stuff but yes and then I got
more you with the gun you with that and
then does anybody else have a weapon you
might have a weapon I'm gonna get you to
what what oh geez
yes yes kill them all kill them all ah
you see duck so the girl got killed
oh geez what a dick go down this way
that's forward and give it a shove it
yeah there we go okay starting to shitty
shop our way down that way right so then
we get that oh no I didn't know I
shouldn't have wasted it out
whoa BAM [ __ ] man she's a lost god damn
it
hey I just don't have all that guys
congregated oh that's because they're
not going down get him get him
oh they're dead Wow alrighty then go up
there go up there fruit oh this is so
cool I like this so don't know that's I
- oh Jesus
don't do that don't go up there
how did that guy get how'd that guy kid
zombie oh did he just have a bad to take
a drug he wasn't supposed to
oh geez now the guys aren't gonna win
because they don't have enough well that
not good that also is not good okay I
guess we're done here
thank you bring on the founda blood yeah
I am the perfect assassin but I'm
handsome so that's consolation prize oh
hello
what the heck are you got to keep
working on this silk loose nah but let
him tell you
there's no anything out phenomenal oh do
you do anything in each other
shame poms a Vinci label mom watches
over that swinging past me available
legally I don't use qualifies as a
scientific process till now know what
you mean while you're scheming avoid
people happening here we are my next
random recipe and improved formula is
nearly ready remember every bra oh boy
well I don't think you're gonna live
much longer to be able to stop all this
so we got to get rid of that thing we
got to break the generator so we can get
in there and get this improved recipe so
if I'm to believe me I've I'm to believe
this this this stupid sack of [ __ ] right
here oh oh he's to be you better run oh
you're not gonna run fast enough are you
hey you're a dick okay then you might
want to shoot faster dude no too late Oh
dead-on jeez oh jeez Scoob what is that
Oh what how do i how do I do the
Overlord you go that way oh oh oh oh
whoa
what the Freak happen to you is that all
you do you just sprout a weird ball sack
legs and then you tell people which way
to go alrighty then dr. Romero your days
might be numbered because this is
getting weird and I like it so before
they fall in that pit I need to get one
of these doodads to go the other way
huh okay so I need to blam these guys
Hey go that way huh hey over there hey
you might want to go over there as much
better over there hey
look at that stuff yeah I thought so I
thought as much as that thing all right
you guys did good right please sacrifice
a zombie to get more DNA okay how about
this guy bub
oh jeez I'm sorry Larry oh god I'm sorry
well anyway it was for a good cause I
suppose maybe no idea I love it I love
it what's next create an epidemic and
killed 25 humans challenge find the
secret drug stash oh really
well where is the secret wow this is the
sprawling level the secret drug stash is
that it okay so I can't even can't even
whoa oh that's cool it's like a puzzle
what I have to do is I have to make this
guy go that way Hey Hubbs Begum's Hey
okay you guys got that all right now Oh
God
burger broke a goodbye okay so I need
them all down there first in a staging
area before they break that door down
like mindless idiots okay so if I go
down this way I will be able to get the
secret stash but it looks like there's
land mines if I'm not mistaken those are
100% land mines but if I go this way I
think this will work I think I can do
this but I definitely no want to go that
way because that's land mines again
I should probably collect more before I
go there though that would be a good
idea yeah let's do that
yeah let's go up first get more ruin the
selfie party get back down there collect
that three whatever that is I want that
number three and then do whatever I need
you to oh that lady is gonna open the
door to a nightmare
what well sorry I love the guy in the
coffee
ah want that three give me that three
bring that to me
ah it's [ __ ]
okay well Lisa wasn't off enough of a
fall to kill me so I can get down there
and that's good and then we can break
that door no won't be able to go to do
don't you guys worry about a thing I
don't want to deal with the guy with the
gun I want to get down here deal with
these guys and then I you know have a
good don't go through that door dude
okay Ramos key ah grass Mike you're in a
bit of trouble here oh he's dead oh no
oh god no we hand their bit to stack a
dude Hey ah dude ah dude dude dude oh
geez they're too stacked up oh no
they're too stacked up oh god all my
sorrows oh geez I'm not gonna make it oh
geez I'm not gonna make it yeah oh geez
have a few good a few okay they made it
holy [ __ ]
oh that lady should have moved it but I
made it to the secret drug stash and
that's what's important already then so
we got that I don't know why there was a
number three there but apparently it was
not something that I actually needed but
I got enough of these guys to be able to
get through and then get through this
level all my zombo's are up here so what
I need to do is I need to get the guy
guns fine there's a five in a Tannen
what does that mean I don't understand
through here break that one oh that's
gonna break down oh that's the number
required to break it down oh okay
first off I'm gonna get you oh no oh so
three you're gonna break that down nice
oh I see okay so I need to put this guy
here
hey go that way hey guys go that hey no
it's dangerous it's dangerous he's a
safety worker this guy's a goddamn hero
with his pulsating Boston hello we're
here now
yeah you all are scared I don't think
huddling in a ball is gonna help anybody
in this situation nope didn't help you
Wow oh that's lovely
hey hey stop that hey hey you
oh you don't feel so good do you oh you
left the door open like a dingus - right
so I need to get rid of this guy you
need to get people wait no not that guy
oh wait like this guy this this guy go
that way half way we're not done
oh that would have been a much easier
way to go about this ah I'm an idiot
ah I'm dumb dumb a big go dumb dumb dumb
dumb okay but I did it yay
I killed everybody fool Jesus and I got
the challenge I don't know what that did
but I got it
alright so what's next oh jeez okay
here's the safe we got to open if we get
paid careful with the explosive mix
you'll get that safe open easily but
it's really unstable I'll treat it like
a rare butterfly oh oh Jesus Oh God why
do you do that is that something I can
use to turn my zombies into horrifying
explosive zombies okay but anyway I am
going to pause this here because I'm all
out of time for this episode this game
is really cool I want to play more of
this so that's exactly what I'm gonna do
I can't wait to get more of a
seems really cool it's a weird mixture
of like a puzzle game because you have
to be tactical with where your zombies
go and also it's just a brutal rampage
of zombies and I love it so I'm gonna
play more of this thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
think of this down the comments below
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]